okay thank you
okay we made our decision and um we're
going to
allow the license um and we notice
that there are no representations from
the police
or the environmental health office we
recognize that the nature of the
surrounding area has changed
with the building of recent residential
developments in the causeway
and the possibility of further
developments
these properties could easily be
impacted
uh um by by the
by the club i know however
we were on on the revelers from
um from altringham town centre
we can't say that all these issues are
down to totties
we will however remind the applicant
that it's their responsibility to make
sure
that as much as possible that their
customers do not cause any issues
for the residents and we would encourage
the applicant
to let the residents have his number in
case there are any issues in the future
so that's the decision
obviously we hope that there are no
further issues
um and with the applicant giving the rep
the residents that are present here
tonight is number
they will make representations in case
there are any further issues
so there'll be no further business
tonight i would like to close the
meeting
and i would thank everybody for their
attendance
okay thank you thank you thank you